aufsteigende rauchwolken kampfflugzeuge
an der türkisch syrischen grenze
türkische kampfflieger bombardieren
mutmaßliche stellungen der kurdischen
volkes verteidigungs einheiten im norden
syriens der einsatz olivenzweig ist vom
türkischen regierungschef binali
yildirim mittlerweile bestätigt zuvor
hatte präsident recep tayyip erdogan in
steyr den militäreinsatz angekündigt der
einsatz gegen afrika hat de facto
begonnen als nächstes ist man mit strand
april und das 100 kilometer weiter
östlich gelegene man mit gehören zur
halb autonomen kurdenregion im
nordwesten syriens
ankara will einen zusammenschluss der
kurdengebiete und die entstehung einer
eigenständigen kurdenregion verhindern
die russische regierung äußert sich
besorgt über die offensive das
außenministerium in moskau ruft die
gegnerischen parteien zur zurückhaltung
auf